et maintenant on a les mois ils sont
trois
si jean paul rouve
le mont saint jean paul super est-ce que
tu as croisé marilyn manson dracula
ouais en fait mary et max haute parce
que c'est quoi c'est le fils de john
benson deux avec richard berry c'est
l'enfant c'est l'enfant qu'ils ont eue
avec richard berry pour ça qu'après ce
sont des adieux tu sais que c'est le
futur gendre de chantal d'affaires
gigantesque jeu est bien sûr paul alors
jean paul je vais être obligé de te vous
voyez là encore rosie ces genres
l'interview et oui je comprends alors
jean paul bonsoir vous avez reçu le 22
février le césar du meilleur jeune
espoir masculin bon ouais
m
pour orange le vrai bien sûr dans
messieurs le miel de gérard jugnot
manille